claire bonsoir mais 82 un an déjà que
les roses sont au pouvoir
qu'évoque pour vous cet anniversaire
nous sommes allés le demandent et madame
du château pâtissière à pauvres sur mer
nous on aime notre métier mon mari les
pattes ici moi je suis à la caisse pour
nous même si aujourd'hui on a la nex
devant la plage et qu'on fait des bonnes
saisons avec les gaufres faut pas
oublier que joël et moi quand on a
démarré on n'avait pas ça et maintenant
faut dire ce qui est on n'est pas bon
pour pourquoi
pourquoi
parce que comme la gauche est passé
nos fonds de commerce adios
tous les couches de nationaliser
les blues sont et si les petits bonnets
très avenant les mules à pompons tout ce
qui fait la vraie pâtissière bye bye
tout le monde en gris souris on sera pas
son avantage
moi je suis pas tranquille
d'ailleurs dès maintenant se décider
comme la gauche est passé les
certificats de baptême des gosses dans
le four à pain ça laisse pas de trace
tous les gars doux genre mariages
communions baptêmes trône droite
moi je peux plus prendre ce risque qui
les refusent je préfère rater des ventes
aujourd'hui que de risquer de me faire
des ans demain pour des bêtises comme la
gauche et bat avec joël le soir on
travaille la pâte d'amande
croyez moi c'est pas commode enfin
heureusement ça commence à rendre on a
line in au bolchoï monté sur génoise qui
est au poil
mais joël a encore beaucoup de boulot
avec sa pièce montée karl marx à cheval
sur le kremlin
c'est la barbe en chantilly au bout de
20 minutes
ça dégringole forcément à 100 et du
travail mais comme dit joël comme la
gauche est passée font mieux du côté du
marteau
du
e